To navigate,
there's two things you need to know when
the first is where the hell are you
exactly,
precisely right.
Razor Sharp,
what's good about you and what's bad
about you by your own buy your own
reckoning.
You don't have to.
You can ask other people,
but this is a game you play yourself.
It's like as far as I'm concerned,
I'm taking star.
What is it that's okay about being what
needs some work and you've got to watch
to not be too self critical when you're
doing that too,
because that can just be another kind of
flaw and then the next is,
okay,
well where are you going?
What's your destination?
Well,
and that's what the frame is.
Now you know you could do that in a very
sophisticated way and you do that by
thinking consciously about who it is
that you are in an articulated manner
and where you want to go and why and how
you're going to get there,
and people hardly ever do that.
That is,
that's come as such an absolute shock to
me as an educator.
I just,
because one of the other programs,
I use this in my classes,
what are the other programs in this
suite of programs is called the future
authoring program and I started
developing my maps of meaning class,
which is where some of this materials
from andI got students to write about
their past.
It's like,
okay,
we're,
we're talking about stories,
so let's tell your story.
Who are you,
how'd you get here,
and what are you now.
That usually helps people put things to
rest.
Although it's quite stressful.
Well,
you're doing it.
Stress goes up when you're doing it and
maybe you feel miserable for a couple of
weeks and then stress goes down and it
stays down.
So that's.
And that's also why people don't do it
because who the hell wants to have their
stress go up?
But if it's temporary,
it's a sacrifice.
So then the next issue is,
well,
where are you going?
And one of the things that,
and this I just still,
I cannot understand you.
Students that had been in education
system for 15 years,
14 years,
high end students.
Most of them,
not once in their whole bloody life.
Did anyone ever get them to sit down for
like a day and say,
all right,
justify your existence.
Like plus.
Seriously.
It's like,
here you are in university.
You're taking a bunch of courses,
you've got some sort of vague career
plan.
It's like defending the damn thing a bit
since you're going to go live it and
everything.
You're staking everything on it.
It's like,
what's your damn plan and why are you so
convinced that it's not the plan of a
babbling fool because if you haven't
thought about it,
it is and if you really want to go out
there and live that out,
you know one of the things Carl Jung
said was that you,
you're in a story whether you know it or
not,
and then he made two nice comments about
that.
If it's someone else's story,
you're probably going to get a bit part
and it might not be the one you want,
and if it's a story that you don't know,
it might be one with a really bad ending
or maybe it's just bad period with a
worse ending,
and if you don't know what the story
that you're living out is,
maybe that's the one you know.
Maybe you got that from your mother.
You got it from your grandmother,
you got it from your or God only knows
where you picked it up because you pick
up things like mad because that's what
human beings are like.
So maybe you're living a malevolent
tragedy unconsciously and then one thing
you might ask yourself is,
well,
how wretched and miserable is your life?
That said,
few title to that,
how wretched,
miserable and futile is your life.
And you might say,
well,
70 percent on each count.
It's like,
then you're probably unconsciously
living out a malevolent tragedy and
maybe that's not for the best.
Oh,
it's either that or the whole universe
hates you,
right?
Or 70 percent hates you,
you know,
so.
So anyways,
you know,
we got students to start writing in
detail about not what they wanted.
It's not a career thing because that's
the closest people usually get is they
have a career plan.
It's like,
no,
it's not a career plan.
That's,
that's peripheral important.
But peripheral,
it's like,
all right,
you got three years,
man,
you're going to live them anyways.
Devote those three years to setting the
world up around you so that it's the
best it can possibly be for you as if
you were taking care of yourself as if
you cared for yourself.
But what would that look like?
You know,
let's say just for the sake of argument,
if you figured out where you were that
you could have,
what would be best for you?
Well,
what is that?
I bet you never asked.
People don't ask and so life comes out
them like random snakes and they sort of
fend them off and life goes by and
things don't work out the way people
expected them to.
But a huge part of that is they didn't
know where they were because they
wouldn't look or didn't know that they
should look ignorance and willful
blindness,
right to great catastrophes,
and they never figured out where they
wanted it to go or why.
Now there's a problem with figuring out
where you want to go.
And the problem is is that you make your
conditions for failure clear to yourself
and people don't like that.
So if you keep yourself in the fog,
then you can't tell when you screwed up.
Now that isn't so good because you're
still screwing up.
You're just to blind self blind to
notice.
Although in in,
in the short term that's less painful.
If you make your criteria for success
are razor sharp,
then you know every time you screw up.
But that's great because then you could
fix it.
You can either repair the,
the,
the behavioral inadequacy or that
conceptual inadequacy that you're using
as a tool in that situation.
Or maybe you could adjust your damn plan
either way you can fix it.
And so,
okay,
so you're living in one of these bloody
things and you might as well,
it seems to me you might as well make it
the best one you could live in because
you don't have anything better to do.
Now,
if you don't do that,
if you don't do it consciously,
and this is what the psychoanalyst
pointed out is that you have innumerable
quasi autonomous subsystems that make
you up,
that will generate stories impulsively
and you'll just act them out.
And you know that because you watch
yourself over two weeks and you think,
Jesus,
I did a lot of stupid things in the last
two weeks.
And you think,
why?
And it's because you're a random.
You're a collection of somewhat random,
quasi autonomous personality units and
lacking a leader.
They're just going to fire off whenever
they want.
You know,
first you're hungry,
then you're thirsty.
Then you want to go to bed with your
wife,
you know,
then you want to sleep in and you want
to tell your boss off.
Then you want to curse at the guy that
cuts you off in traffic.
It's like you're kind of like a two year
old,
you know,
just it's one emotional frame after
another vying for dominance.
There's no overarching hierarchy and
there's no king at the top.